galera
vamos parar com o clima do funeral deixa
eu falar para vocês eu hoje eu acho que
eu tô muito mais acho que eu tô muito
mais feliz do que quando eu cheguei aqui
às vezes eu tô fazendo uma coisa normal
uma coisa bem tranquila assim sei lá
compra no sorvete comendo um picolé e do
nada chegou uma pessoa cara
academia tá cheia todo dia velho
rapaz fazia tempo que eu não via ali
valeu não pede foto não pede nada só faz
sair quando eu luto tipo ia acontece
isso aqui a parte mais mais feliz que
tem minha é isso aí se eu ver que isso
está acontecendo para mim eu tô vencendo
todas as lutas se eu tivesse ganhando
todas as lutas e eu não tivesse sentindo
a parada que eu sinto quando quando o
cara pega em mim e fala assim
ajuda a academia tá viu velho
porque tá ganhando 12:15 ia ser aquele
cara que 20 luta 0 derrota e Ia sentar
em casa e falar assim o que que eu tô
fazendo da minha vida eu sei muito o que
eu tô fazendo